[Music]
joining me today is a consumer reporter
a former host on ABC's 20/20 and on Fox
Business Network a 19 time Emmy winner
and now a host on reason TV as well as a
decent fella john stossel finally
welcome to the rubin report finally good
to be I am I'm really glad to have you
because I put in decent fella in the
intro there because I've been watching
you for probably 30 some odd years on
Friday nights when I was growing up my
family would all watch 20/20 together
and you would come on there and you'd be
you know going to all these businesses
or talking to government regulators or
all this stuff and more than anything
else as just a kid watching this stuff
just learning about ideas you always
struck me as just very decent are you a
decent guy you can't be a total [ __ ]
and succeed on TV
you can't cuz I'm pretty sure there's
plenty of those but yeah that's true I
mean Bill O'Reilly's kind of but on
20/20 just felt the day would not have
work is that decency when I talked to
libertarians now I was just telling you
a little bit before we started a little
bit about my own political evolution
when I go to schools now and I talked to
all these libertarian groups and I'm
invited all these places and the
students for Liberty and all this stuff
I find that the libertarian crew as a
general rule is just very decent like
it's really people who don't seem to
want to get in your way they just want
to live their life how embedded in you
was that always were you always that way
no I and I don't even know for sure that
I'm that waiting I'm a hungry guy I'm
angry and when I was a consumer reporter
I was pissed off at those businesses
that were ripping people off I wanted to
humiliate them and jail them which I
couldn't do but I could humiliate them
on TV and now I'm angry at the big
government
but to present something on 20/20 and
make this more accessible I had to tone
that down yeah so I guess that's most
people are decent aren't then I hate
politicians but most I met are basically
decent people yeah I agree I do think
most people are decent I think most
people are live and let live
I guess that's you're making an
interesting distinction there it's sort
of like you were angry about these
issues but the the persona that you have
I suppose created or the person that we
know the john stossel that we know is
kind of a decent fella as opposed to
just because everyone else on cable news
is just yelling all day long yeah I
never could get into the young and I
never really fit in that well in most
Fox talk shows once I went to Fox yeah
so tell me a little bit about your own
political evolution because you weren't
always quite a libertarian right no no
no it was a garden-variety leftist and I
graduated from Princeton my professors
explained that we now know what works
and we don't want to lift people out of
poverty we just need these programs it's
inexcusable in this rich country that
some people are still poor and we have
welfare we're gonna fix it this way then
I became a reporter by accident and
started in Portland Oregon
and I'm a starter so I didn't want to be
on the beat with everybody else shouting
questions of politicians because I
thought I might humiliate myself okay
and I looked around for well what else
could I cover so I became a consumer
reporter which if you think about it
includes most of life within politics
the weather and crime which was just
about all they covered them science
psychology business that is in all kinds
of things and in doing that I won 19
Emmy Awards bashing businesses the
cheating people I turned out to be good
at that and I gradually saw that the
regulations that consumer reporters were
calling for all the time in
first of all watching the poverty
programs fail in Portland was one step
one story we did was to the consumer
front to take a TV set that had a loose
park to about 20 different repair shops
and eighteen would say ah just lose part
struggle thing in its finding by no
charge to would say I'm gonna have to
keep this over the weekend we came back
they charge a lot of money and I would
say well why would you keep me went just
analyze why would you say this one just
had a loose part oh I never said that
oh yeah we'll watch this or we play the
video and it was great television and
yeah politicians would call the station
and say that's good we're gonna pass a
law and young john stossel was all
excited and not paying attention to me
and i got the law passed in in oregon
they didn't pass a the park baby to
create a department that consumer
affairs partly because of this report
and it felt great to me but then i
stayed on the consumer of fairness b and
i noticed later these regulations didn't
make any difference we do all the tests
most people were honest and a few would
she does that so what were these what
was the Department of Consumer Affairs
doing well they were licensing repair
shops that's not good to people with
licensed drivers be licensed dogs but
what it really meant was there's a big
room where bureaucrats it around fill
out forms and people who are savvy go
get their licenses and raises the price
a fraction other people have to pay
lawyers because he can't understand all
the stuff the people who wanna move up
in life maybe immigrants maybe people
here illegally they don't dare order the
licensing department they then work in
black market that creates its own
problems the more I looked around the
more I saw these unintended consequences
from these regulations and steeped in
the New York Times and the liberal media
I started looking for other
stuff to read I read the conservative
press but they seem to want to invade
people's bedrooms the national sexuality
or going by wars with everybody I didn't
like them either and then I discovered
recent magazine which was listening oh
this is great yeah I love that I love
that story because it's like you were
what about oh is that it right there
it's my new comedy just came in the mail
yeah
very nice very nice and Virginia posture
Elle's writing was the one that really
lifted my brain and I started then
reading more to became a libertarian
stop winning any awards totally won
media's for the compliance did I need to
put an asterisk next to the 19 that I
mentioned before yeah yeah self
congratulatory stuff given away my
status at least you're you're not
looking for the 20th I think that's what
we learned here Oh are they cut are they
coming to get you right now I wouldn't
mind one of the I would like you know
I've got this nice set here I wouldn't
mind putting one over there but you can
hang on to it for now but I love that
story because it's so interesting
because you started going after these
businesses then because of what you're
doing the politicians get involved and
then you very quickly realize that maybe
you were going after the wrong people
even though you were doing good work but
that the real issue was something that
you had discovered throughout this
process which i think is just such an
interesting way to figure out what you
actually believe and that's true except
for the very quickly part I think the
people who listen to your podcast
they're smarter than I and use you
figure this out much more quickly than I
did well I'm still figuring it out you
know well we're almost figured out but
you figured out the folly of the statism
yes so what is it about regulation that
makes people feel good because I again I
remember watching you when you were
doing all of this on 20/20 and this is
what you were really talking about often
that these the government comes in and
there's regulators and there's
bureaucrats and there's red tape and
that it actually almost every week you'd
be saying but it actually doesn't
accomplish anything other than
complicating things and as you said it
gets more lawyers involved and drives up
costs and all this other stuff but why
is it that inherently it seems like when
when people come in with regulations or
extra laws or whatever it is it somehow
makes the population feel okay even if
there is no evidence for that
and in fairness it there is summon as it
does a little good some bad guys are
deterred or punished mm-hmm but it's
just instinct to want to trust a rule
people that when they see something they
say they're gonna be a law and even I
say that one thing's piss me off
surprise first reaction and why get mean
why is that because we grew up was
parents who managed our lives
and that made us feel safer or because
for thousands of years of evolution
people lived in tribes of under 200
people and if he didn't harvest the
fruit when the elders said you died so
your ancestors were able to give birth
to you because they listened to those
experts and took that guidance by
contrast the invisible hand is just hard
to process mm-hmm is this a little bit
of the the conflict within
libertarianism zyou no it's always going
to Liberty to freedom to personal
responsibility and all that and yet at
the same time as a society as a group of
people trying to live within borders
with some set of rules that we actually
do need some constraints to keep us you
know they're basically to just keep the
the the clock ticking otherwise we'd all
just be living in anarchy true and I
think most libertarians are comfortable
with that and we need rule of law it's
what made Hong Kong prosperous it just
50 years they went from third and pearl
the first world because they had what
you need to make a society work the
British rulers punished people who
killed or stole but then they did
something wonderful they said around the
threat T and by leaving the people alone
three people made themselves rich so I
would go beyond that and say you need
Pollution Control knows not everyone
agrees you could could sue the polluter
but it just doesn't seem to work well
under our system I there's a public
square there should be some rules for
the public square the Constitution has a
bunch of rules the question is how many
and we only have a few yeah and we don't
seem to be having this conversation
really very effectively so I'm glad you
brought up the environment so this is
one where my my libertarian side kind of
wants to leave everything to private
companies and yet I've had enough
climate scientists on the show and I've
talked to enough people who know more
about this than me and they feel
generally that some regulation is needed
without going too far down the the
climate change conversation although if
you want to we can how do you figure out
what is the right thing to do how do you
figure out what's the amount that is
okay for the private sector to deal with
and how much the public sector should
deal with that's a job sad to say for
government we have to have some limited
or making some of those decisions the
problem is the EPA and what it was
wonderful when it was introduced when
they passed rules making cars cleaner
putting catalytic converters in the
exhaust and scrubbers and smokestacks
and the air and water got cleaner when
when I was your age couldn't open a
window in it so it's because set live
coming but regulators always there
they're there and then they want to do
more and idiot politicians keep adding
to the numbers George Bush George w was
called D regulator but he added 90,000
regulators huh I don't think that would
have a little more but each one of those
guys thinks he's not doing his job
unless he's addict
something in the global warming case
it's not pollution it's just carbon
dioxide it doesn't hurt anybody's lungs
it may be a problem this the climate
change and man probably is making it
worse but there's nothing we can do
about it now so it's not a time for
government action because all the stuff
we're doing now is pointless and might
make a fraction of the security
difference so let's wait until we have
the science there were we really might
do something yeah so what would you say
to the people that just say well the
science is totally settled because this
is one of the ones where I'm happy to
have the conversation either way and
I've had people on both sides of this
come on but people get get very
defensive over this topic even if you
were just to say even if you said the
science was settled right now but said I
still want less government involvement I
don't think it's something the
government could handle there would
still be just like a tremendous amount
of anger over a comment like that my
answer is when you say the science is
Senate well settled about which part
there are four parts to it climate
changes yeah and that climate changed
the night or climate changes its being
warming since the Little Ice Age is it
gonna be it doesn't number two is man
contribute there it's not 98% that agree
but most agree the far-left says it's
all Dan's fault but that's ridiculous
because it was warming long before man
but man contributes is it a crisis then
that's an argument and there's no
unanimity there malaria is that a crisis
a million dead every year dysentery we
got bill crises in the world they're
just going broke won't be able to pay
for old geezers like me those are crises
but forth is there anything we can do
about it
no and the science is settled on that
solar won't working it it's just not
enough of it possible and it takes
fossil fuels to build the solar panels
and truck up to the site if they cause
unintended consequences - yeah why do
you think we we
just want to throw money at everything
you know as I've had my evolution here I
it's so obvious to me that we have
spending problems that we're always just
spending on everything we don't really
see results so many of the things that
you've talked about over the years and
yet the answer even for right now what I
see on the Left often is government's
horrible Trump is evil everything's
terrible but we have to make government
bigger let's make it bigger and give it
more money and let it take more I mean
if the logic seems completely well it
seems completely antithetical to logic
how about that why do we always want to
throw money at things and not look at
where we can actually cut because it's
other people's money and talking about
cutting politically is poisonous so is
that is there is there any resolution on
that I mean if all these politicians
just want to get in and as you said
earlier they want to do something they
feel like they have to do something then
really it's almost an unwinnable and you
know they're running for re-election the
day they get elected in the first place
so we're really in sort of a toxic mess
because of the political machine right
totally and no kid goes to the state
capitol the media's legislators and asks
what laws have you repealed for instance
says you gotta do more and I don't know
how it will end I don't think it's gonna
end well the white in Germany and Japan
prosper economically so much of the 50s
and 60s because we bombed them the
smithereens during World War two got rid
of all their layers of rules and their
gills they started over economically and
that made it much easier to prosper but
now we can't even get rid of farm
subsidies and corporate welfare like
that yeah where do you think Trump falls
on all this stuff I mean I think
generally the libertarians kind of like
it seems like he's cutting some
regulation or at least he said he's
gonna you know what was it for every one
that we passed we have to cut three or
something something like that
was it - okay I was yeah so who knows if
that's even true but
generally there's the idea within what
we think of him that he wants to cut
some of the regulation scale back
government a little bit lower taxes
things like that and yet there's also
this other part of him that I think most
people agree there's absolutely an
authoritarian side that you know all the
trade stuff what do you think his
ideology even is related to all of this
I have no clue if even if he does I'm
sure he'd be the first to say there
ought to be a law and I'll fix that like
the wonderful thing is the people he's
appointed somehow
many of them are great and they're
people who really understand this some
of them work for reason how they're
working in the Trump administration and
it's hard to dismantle these rules and
that statement which is catchy for every
new rule we got a repeal two old one sir
I got one two spots a little London
saying it for years in that won't work
because the regulators will just game it
they'll pass a big rule and they'll
repeal two trivial things but the people
Trump's appointed some of them get this
which I could have never dreamed what
happened and they are a mystery so
you're kind of hopeful then I sense some
hopefulness there no yes no I don't the
economy has had the ability to grow
faster than the state and Strang a lot
of futures so the internet was a
wonderful way to get around regulation
for a while I don't think it's any
accident that blossomed in the two
metropolitan areas farthest from
Washington DC you know now they're
lobbying all up and they're in bed with
government but innovation like that has
kept the economy growing almost as fast
as government if they would just grow
government 2% a year we could grow out
of the horrible deficit we're in but
they don't
every year they increases by more than
the rate of inflation yeah
it's interesting you mentioned San
Francisco in Seattle so one of the
things that we've been talking about
here because obviously we put this show
on YouTube is how big Google has become
how their ability to control the
information we have their ability to let
me have access to my own audience
through the YouTube algorithm things
like that and I've been seeing lately
that there's been a cry on the right for
people that want to break Google up
treat it as a monopoly or as a public
utility or something like that now the
the libertarian part of me does not want
that at all the idea that the government
would come in even for a company that is
as large as Google and all the problems
that creates do you have any feelings on
that one way or another as to whether
Google is possibly too big because right
now it's controlling virtually all of
the information we get I shifted my
thinking on that
my first libertarian reaction is people
say well the whatever you need
government to keep business from getting
too big is this monopoly power but IBM
was sued for nine years because they
were supposedly a monopoly it's just a
waste of money and Microsoft was sued
new competitors the barriers to entry
are not what they once were Google gets
arrogant
Facebook gets arrogant somebody else's
step forward to punish them and a friend
of mine from college John tackle another
book saying they're too big and they
have too much power I concluded but when
Google fired this guy for saying anymore
James dam or for saying obviously true
things about differences between genders
and having a reasonable proposal about
it it take me off and I tried to switch
off Google go to Bing and not use it to
some personal statement yeah found it
impossible and as you watch them buy up
the competitors I would just hate the
things that some bureaucrat is gonna
make the decision but think conceivably
could be a threat yeah this is one where
I'm still 50/50 on this idea of having
the government come in and do it
seems terrible to me and the idea
this one seems much more dangerous
actually to me than what IBM was doing
20 years ago and and even what Microsoft
was doing with Windows and all that this
one sees more danger cause it's really
the totality of our information so yeah
we can all sort of do the Bing thing
ourselves and make it all about the
individual which is what my default is
but I think there might be something a
little extra pervasive here but I don't
have a settled answer on it and we're
gonna bus is forced to use Facebook yeah
well not yet anyway but but we shall we
shall see oh it should have been the
essential question that would have it I
thought convinced the left eye I met
with one left he says right you guys are
all going on about government power why
not business power because government
gets to use force and no business can
they have to invite us to use their
products that was an epiphany for me
really think about how much harm they
can do if we can always say no we'll
take our business elsewhere so
fundamentally yeah so fundamentally you
believe that competition itself is the
great regulator that ultimately if we
have an even playing field at least on
who can get in that that really will
force companies which of course they're
gonna try to maximize profits and you
know I see all the time you know a guy
who I've loved for many years
every time they cut a regulation Bill
Maher will scream about how well their
companies are gonna start dumping in the
water again
and it's like well actually everyone has
Twitter and snapchat and Instagram now
and they'd be called out on it and the
public outcry would be so quick that I
think it actually causes them to
self-regulate a little bit more very
true so in the case of your example I
would say Bill Maher's fans would say
yeah but you're not out on the ship way
out in the ocean when they're sneaking
those phones in the water that's why we
need these rules right so what's the
answer to that nobody's getting rid of
the rules we've got a million rules all
these current people are doing is saying
this new one that the Obama
administration wanted to add we're not
going to
there's not enough evidence it's brings
more benefits than costs but nobody's
getting rid of the old rules yeah let's
uh let's shift a little bit just sort of
talk about media in general because as
somebody that's been part of mainstream
media for a long time and now you're
you're working with the reason guys so
you're doing a little more of sort of
what I'm doing with the with the online
world do you sense as sort of succinctly
or keenly as I said that mainstream
media is just absolutely crumbling right
now for better or worse are crumbling
isn't that much people still go to the
Wall Street Journal the New York Times
they found ways to make people enough
people pay for the product or contribute
as you do so their mainstream it's just
nice that they have this competition I
was at ABC bernard goldberg law came out
by uh it was not just a bestseller
number one bestseller huge festival and
that was and it was right along about
left-wing bias and i would say to people
at ABC what did you think about it and
nobody had read it nobody was interested
I think it was this feeling of we're
just the reasonable people in the middle
and those weird conservatives they're
evil they it's not it is facile you're
the only guy in the building with a
point of view there I mean I think at
least now with all these alternatives
the people at ABC many of who move to
MSNBC at least never they know that
people consider them leftists it's
improved right I guess that's an
improvement but it's still pretty
obvious that as a general rule the media
it skews left and now you know there's
some of us out here doing this but I see
the crumbling of it even though yeah
Wall Street Journal's do and find times
I guess they said they're subscribership
as as high as always but that generally
especially for young people they're just
not consuming information in those ways
anymore regardless of what the political
event is
true and I'm far from a young person but
because I play beach volleyball I'd
become hooked on Facebook and I do
notice in my newsfeed people are sending
a lot of articles from the Atlantic the
Wall Street Journal reason Forbes
mainstream media so it's become part of
the young people's Twitter and Facebook
feeds and as my own son works in social
media who talked me into leaving my
shoulder Fox and doing this stuff on the
web says you don't need a network
anymore because we have Facebook and
this will reach more people but the
danger is the filter ball and the
algorithms were so good at noticing if I
if I listen to this one a second one
fraction of a second longer I respond a
certain way they'll give me more of that
so people get more intensely locked into
their biases because they have a whole
bunch of other people sure yeah do you
think we should that the algorithm
itself should be sort of open source
that we should all understand what the
algorithm is because I don't think
people really even understand what you
just said right there I mean I think my
audience gets it but the average person
doesn't understand that the more you you
click this that you're just going to get
more of it that we're self building the
walls that are closing us off and we
should tell people and encourage people
to reach outside their walls but
wouldn't elvish if you took away
Facebook's private property and demanded
they reveal the algorithm then I don't
know what we gain from that we already
know that in it it wants to keep your
eyeballs longer and it gives you more
what you seem to spend more time yeah
wait tell me more about your son telling
you to leave mainstream or leave Fox
Business that's really fascinating we
were you thinking about it and then he
just nudged you or it was he really
pushing you in that direction I was
feeling a little stressed when my show
every week and felt I hit in seven years
done much of what I wanted to do and I
use
tinea and three or four year contracts
and Wallace Davis Fox but now I was in
hearing Fox because the boss was first
sick and then being investigated for
being horrible / and I thought I better
make some other plans for myself so I
wrote the Rupert Murdoch and said let me
do some outside things and started
talking to donors would you support me
if I just put this stuff straight to
media my son Max had said and nobody's
gonna what you know person's gonna
believe anything you say if you say it
the Fox aim and we live in New York City
with that it's certainly true here might
as well but it gives you the credibility
it's a network yeah try Twitter here no
I don't have a million Twitter followers
it is a waiter you know reach on but it
is a new way to reach people yeah do you
miss any of the network side of things
do you miss any of you know I'm sure you
know your studio at Fox Business was
probably you know great a top of the
line and everything like that
do you miss any of that just sort of
there's a certain comfort factor better
than that's a very impressive office
nobody's putting down that office ah I
certainly don't miss any see we're 2020
it's just got the students just freak of
the week anybody who wants news now
those two one of the cable network and
I'm still working for Fox on the
contributors so found the right balance
no I don't have to do it and the
hour-long show every week and I get to
craft the videos which is my main skill
yeah what do you make of the way people
talk about Fox all the time you know Fox
Business I guess gets it a little less
but the the general if you look at what
the media and what celebrities and
everyone that's yammering on on Twitter
all day long is always saying about Fox
because it's interesting I the only
network that I really get invited on to
is Fox and I've done O'Reilly and I've
done Tucker and Greg Gutfeld who I think
or you know especially Greg and
who i know pretty well are good guys but
there's this like just endless
relentless hate of fox do you think any
of its warranted is any what what are
your feelings for as much as you can
tell me it does it is right-wing and if
you hate the right then you're gonna
hate them they have on occasion go on in
my opinion too far i'm not going to give
examples like an even think of examples
at the moment to deserve it but most of
it is just because the left was never
used to having any opposition let alone
in opposition that out raided them and
rachel head out now is leading in the
rage the highest-rated show fox overall
still is number one of the ratings and
you can end me but the success and
resentment of that yeah you can't miss
having to worry about ratings right like
do you even do you even think about
cliques at this point or you put your
content out there you you know you're
liked and that a certain amount of
people are watching i mean but that
endless ratings chase must be just
miserable miserable is too strong but it
does make you edgy and when i took this
job i thought gosh you know i can just
work with smart people and think takes
and put out a better video than they
would have cause a lot of the movements
videos suck and they'll be better it
doesn't matter how many people watch and
i won't worry about them but no i can
totally check in the number of clicks
i'm addicted to it i want success and
success is measured that way yeah i want
success too but i try not to get too
caught in the clicks because I find you
start going crazy there's you can watch
live tickers and it's just not a
sensible thing to be doing let's talk a
little bit about the libertarians as a
political entity I've had Gary Johnson
on the show I've spent some time with
him privately I thought he was a very
decent guy I voted for him despite
some very public flubs on things the
party itself seems like just an absolute
disaster I've had libertarians on here
that agree with me on that and some that
disagree with me on that what do you
think I wouldn't say absolute disaster
but it has a lot of fringe people who
give libertarians a bad name and I agree
with you about Johnson a very decent guy
he wasn't the best political talker but
when you say the you voted for him as I
did too in spite of the flubs some of
the floods were unfair and I want to
point out that the Aleppo I would have
done the same thing they were not
talking about Foreign Affairs they were
talking about American politics and this
report or sublease ISM what would you do
about a level I would have said about
leopards wasn't so obvious well I guess
the catch was I guess the catch-22 for
him was that unless he flogged unless he
did something and said something sort of
ridiculous or that didn't make sense or
whatever that he got no coverage anyway
so the only time they covered him was
when he did one of these so he could
have talked about small government and
states rights and all of those things
till he was blue in the face and no one
would have ever talked about it except
for maybe you and me possibly except
nobody likes the existing candidates and
the cable networks were given him a shot
here and there and he just wasn't very
compelling television and this we've
learned from Trump had he been a little
more like Trump in his TV performance he
might have made a big difference yeah is
there anyone I'll do that or I don't
think he could have and I can't even
name somebody who I think would be great
at it
but if something is well that was my
that was my next question I mean why
isn't there someone it seems to me that
the principles of limited government of
personal responsibility of you know of
the individual liberty
these are base
principles that I think actually most
people believe in and yet somehow the
branding of them or something just
hasn't bubbled up to the mainstream so
we don't get candidates that really sell
these things well even a guy like Rand
Paul who I basically like I think there
were so many opportunities where he
could have really staked out his
libertarianism that because he's a
Republican he either couldn't or was
unwilling to do and I find that very
disappointing me too and he came across
as a little sour and not that great
about celebrating the benefits of
freedom but I I think our movement has
too many nerdy white guys I kind of
think esic my fantasy is gonna come from
a Latina woman and the normal resistance
of viewing all of us as fat cats will be
somewhat broken down then she can
explain it well it's not a male
supremacy field as it looks like when
you go to a libertarian party event
awesome but I don't know what it'll take
my wife is a garden-variety liberal and
I've been talking to her for 33 years
now and every time when the problem
comes out in her full up in New York
Times she'll say to me
what about this your instead this is
hard for people especially non nerdy men
you know it's interesting because I
suspect if we went into it that you're
probably no fan of identity politics and
so much obviously of what the left is
about these days and yet at the same
time you're saying maybe it would take a
Latina woman now I know you'd be judging
her as an individual and by her own
thoughts that you would either agree
with or not but it's one of those cases
where you almost have to use identity
politics against them in an odd way
sadly yeah it's it's a damn shame but I
guess that's kind of where we're at wait
let's talk about your wife a little bit
more because I think that's interesting
we there used to be in my family I grew
up my dad leaned a little more right my
mom leaned a little more left and my
extended family we would argue over
politics scream at each other over the
dinner table and then we were all
fine after we don't see that much these
days I get emails probably every week at
this point of people that are defending
their brother on Facebook I've gotten
emails about people that are getting
divorced over politics what do you
think's the trick to being able to stay
married for 30 years as a libertarian
and a liberal how'd you do it I got
marriage counseling it's tough I admit
as I grow older ideas about governance
become more important in my life and to
have a partner who is not cheering me on
is difficult so we have to talk about it
agree not to have that dominate our
whole life but I'm not very good at
preserving these friendships I want to
get in there confirm and because I do
this for a living I tend to have more
information and my bum they say look
here's what your program hasn't worked
and I don't know why you keep pushing it
and he just pisses people off rather
than convinces them yeah we seem to be
afraid to have those conversations right
I mean it's hard just to get people to
you know I agree to disagree okay all
right let's move on there's 350 million
of us we're gonna be okay but yet that
concept seems to be slipping away really
fast people want information they don't
want to have to say to you are what's
the best argument your wife's put in
front of you when you when you get into
one of these and you're you're talking
about regulation or something or she
throws the New York Times in front of
you and says see we have to do something
about this does she ever move you in any
way that has surprised you no well your
best art is basically your welfare state
abolish the well Thursday that maybe
someday people will stop being so
dependent and they'll learn to take care
of themselves but in the meantime look
at all the suffering this would cause
and I try to say private charities will
step in you don't know that and they
we'll do it right away and they won't do
it for the unpopular people and those
are valid arguments I just think in the
long run the vast majority of people
would be doing better with less milkers
yeah so how do you figure out where that
less ends because I think a lot of my
audiences will be with you on that
concept I I believe in some social
safety net not what we've got right now
it's obvious just all the evidence shows
that it's not working it's actually
keeping people at a certain level of
poverty how do you figure out what the
right amount or rut or what right way
there is to help people that need it the
most
beats me but it should be small enough
that the private sector can compete with
it offer alternatives at least after
this hurricane the current FEMA tell
volunteers no we don't later water it
hasn't been approved and send them away
if they can't ban the competition that
would be good but you know I did during
the Depression when there was no welfare
state like there is no 25% of the
country was out of work already America
was much poorer than and yet the few
exceptions
nobody star people stepped up there were
these mutual aid societies that helped
other people and they were racist they
were blacks helping blacks Koreans
helping Karina's White's weitzel but
they would meet and listen to the pleas
and world and they better know who held
financial help or a kick in the ass and
they did a better job once the welfare
state was created most of those went out
of business as rationally you say oh
well it's not my job anymore there's
this big government other people's money
come through and that'll fix it and so
they're gone but they would come back
right so in a weird way this leftist
ideology really it's it's very
dismissive of what I
think we actually are as people I
fundamentally believe that people are
good that people want to help not only
themselves but their families and their
communities and it's almost as if the
the leftist ideology is really saying no
no if the government won't do it for you
you're just going to be left to your own
devices and you're gonna be evil and
selfish I just don't think that's true
perhaps what your wife saying there may
be a period of time if we got rid of all
this stuff that there would be a problem
before the private companies or private
people stepped in but I do think people
would do more if they were given less I
agree certainly mostly some people are
selfish it do anything for other people
but you don't need all you just need a
few of the billionaires and 25% of the
rest of the people and I think we get
that most of us what I help other people
yeah where do you stand on a universal
basic income I don't know that I've
heard you talk about it specifically but
I've heard some interesting libertarian
arguments on it
I first heard about it from Charles
Murray's book and I love Charles burr in
his book in pursuit of happiness and
good government really lifted my brains
so I want to believe his ideas but no I
don't get it if he gives someone the
$14,000 and whatever it is and the guy
who snorts it up his nose his Society is
the government in that town I'm gonna
just say okay you're not getting any
more we're not going to spend money a
program to help you we're just gonna
lock you up and spend all that money to
do that no I think we get the guaranteed
income plus the welfare state thank you
so basically it's that there would be no
ending which is really where we're at
right now there's no end point where all
right this is the stop point and after
that we don't do anything but even after
that there would always want more there
would always be politicians going well
now we still have to do this so really
you're just compounding the problem I
believe so it certainly would
for some but then other people would say
hey I can get my 14,000 and well sir and
section 8 housing voucher what do you
what do you say - we'll just knock out a
couple issues in a row here $15 minimum
wage you know they passed it up in
Seattle I I was in Seattle a couple
months ago I mentioned this on the show
a few weeks ago and I get to the airport
and right in the airport where they've
passed this $15 minimum wage there's a
McDonald's and instead of having people
they have in effect their iPads there's
touchscreen monitors and probably one
guy that has some you know watch ten of
them and I thought well this is exactly
what the companies we're gonna do
because they've got to make profit how
do you make that point to people without
sounding like some cold evil capitalist
just the way you did and I think this is
one time where more people have gotten
to that oh I hadn't thought of that
point it also helps to say did you know
I know how many people get minimum wage
people think it's 50% of the workforce
it's actually less than five because
most companies on their own have to pay
more to get the workers they want and
another good thing to say is well you're
around 15 we can get a lot easier for
this person to live but 15 is still
tough
why are we so cheating why why not 20
why got a hundred maybe they start to
think about oh I guess this does cause
some distortions yeah is this another
one of those examples where actually
it's the free market that will save us
because you know even right now you know
Amazon bought Whole Foods we're hearing
that they're gonna have these full-on
supermarkets where there's gonna be
basically one employee in the whole
place everything else will be drones and
you know delivered by robots and all
this other stuff where it'll be so
obvious to people that you can't that
humans won't be worth I mean sadly we
just won't be worth the money that
they're demanding we pay people but will
that convince people I don't think so
they'll just say oh that would have
happened they that was just automating
from these greedy talkers there's so
many times I thought well there's look
at this
but it doesn't okay oh no that's
depressing
yeah sorry what gives you the hope then
that would that you keep fighting on you
keep you know you've got a smile I think
you're 70 years old you look like you're
50 you're doing something right I don't
know what is it it's all the mustache
what's going on over there I chose my
appearance careful well done oh but
really what gives you that sense of hope
still to do this all these years to see
things still get screwed up and all of
that and yet want to Trek on want to get
these ideas across I wish I could say I
was super hopeful I know that's not what
motivates me it's just that oh I'm born
again free marketer ie to the luck of
having a job where I was a consumer
reporter I got to watch everyday what
worked and what did I've learned
something and jeez this thing I learned
makes the difference between whether
people have a good life or a bad life
but I know this now and I half-dozen
preach it I have to share it with as
many people as I can or I'm not a decent
human being and I guess I'm hopeful or I
wouldn't keep doing it but just have to
do it even if we're not all right you
sort of have no choice is is any country
doing it better than us right now so
when you hear people complaining about
how horrible our system is and our evil
oppressive government all the horrors of
American history and just everything
that's become so mainstream these days
not to say we don't have legitimate
problems not to say we can't be better
and all of that but is there any country
that you look to that at least on the
economic front is really doing it in a
way that you think makes more sense
sure Hong Kong New Zealand if you look
at all the 15 countries that are now
ahead of us on the economic Liberty
lists they're doing by that measure and
that's pretty good
better than we've been doing and it's
funny some of it is the so-called
socialist company countries of northern
Europe that they're a lot less
economically controlled and American
socialists think they are
and nobody's perfect Singapore is
repressive in other ways but they do a
great job economically yeah so if there
were a couple things if you were run in
the country right now and there were
just you know two or three things that
you could do magic wand to help business
which ultimately helps the rest of us
live believes that you know we want to
live what would those things be repeal
two laws for every new one repealed ten
laws every new when you pass simplify
the tax system even if it raises as much
revenue though I would get rid of whole
departments so I wouldn't have to but
the idea that we're spending so much
time just trying to fill it out or
understand their game the system is
horribly destructive get in the drug war
[Music]
cut all the departments that Cato lists
in downsize government.org and have a
smaller manageable government just
enforced environmental rules and some
public safety rules where are you on the
time the tax thing are you a no taxation
guy are you a flat tax guy I'm not sure
a simple tax guy tanks costs when you
don't cut spending don't do anything
it's the spending the spending has to be
taken from somebody so this current
Republican plan is not impressive so
what would be a fair way do you believe
in any sort of progressive tax like be
sure yeah
fifteen percent should be simply poor
people should be exempt rich people
should pay fifteen and that's
progressive because you don't pay until
you get to a certain level of income
yeah I mean I'm basically around
somewhere with that I would I would even
maybe go a little further that if you're
really into the the tens and hundreds of
millions of dollars you could still tax
them a little bit more I don't know that
even economically it makes sense but I
think there's some like there's just
something I could be convinced on on
that sure I just say fifteen because
that's
what they have a phone call and I think
Estonia some of the new former Soviet
republics tribe that yeah so uh before I
let you go let's talk about reason a
little bit so you're over there you're
free you're doing what you want to do
you don't have to deal with the the
pressures of cable news do you just
basically wake up every morning and like
this is what I'm gonna write about this
is what I'm gonna talk about this is the
story we're gonna do and that's it
that's pretty sweet pretty much except
I'm not that smart I work with four
other people who have their own agendas
and make suggestions so we do it
together I only do one or two a week so
I don't have to make a whole new one
every morning yeah yeah basically yeah
well I think it's great listen as I said
when we started I've admired you for
thirty years at this point I think even
before I realize these ideas about
liberty and freedom and personal
responsibility in all of this stuff I
was watching what's that what you do
with a lot of radios say Liberty in
freedom yeah well what's the difference
between liberty and freedom well there
isn't much of a difference between
liberty and freedom actually thanks for
economy we just pick one everybody says
freedom liberty liberty and freedom
sorry
no no no that's fine you know what for
the purposes of this I'm going to go
with Liberty so even before I realized
what Liberty was and I was watching you
when I was you know a young kid in Long
Island by the way I used to see you
every now and again wandering the Upper
West when you were working at at ABC but
I never harassed you on the street do
you like getting harassed if it's thank
you for what you do that's not
harassment you don't want to be accosted
is that what you're saying well the guy
you said he just fassl yes I hope he
dies too and that's not so nice I really
been accosted and the only time I got
eaten up was by a professional wrestler
before a story who was
dr. David Schultz didn't like my saying
pro wrestling's fake
oh wait and did he body slammed you or
something and then hurt your neck to
line up with somebody else he whacked me
on the side of the head and then when I
stupidly got up again and get me on the
other side that's probably one of my
more watched videos on YouTube at 1:40
alright you know we're gonna find that
one we'll link to it down below
truly it's been a pleasure chatting with
you and next time I see you walking
around I will cost you but I won't say
mean things I promise I'll talk about
liberty or something so for more on John
you guys can check out Stossel on Reason
TV and follow him on Twitter it's at
John Stossel
John thank you so much thanks dude
[Music]
you